let's go rochelle uh congratulations
three victories in a row how does that
feel you're getting close to that
coveted leadership position feels good
i mean it could feel better like if i
like sometimes i still think about like
that game that i should have won but
didn't so i was like during my game when
i was winning i was like this could be
five in a row
but it's not
yeah but it's not let's take a look at
uh today's game because i have to say
out of the opening it just felt like
you're completely dominant yeah how you
felt as well um yeah i actually she put
a lot of moves that i didn't really
expect because i felt like she was being
a little bit passive um
like how she's developing my pieces and
it felt more like she was going
backwards than forwards
and it was like
did you have this prepared in your notes
or um so i completely mixed up my lines
because
like
i i didn't even really know like i still
have no idea
um i think you were doing just fine i
used to play this h3 g4 line yeah um
okay let's keep going
here i was critical of her decision to
play queen c7 it felt passive i thought
rochelle she her basically her best
chance was to play a4 and queen a5 that
was that on your radar
yeah i i thought she would do something
like that too
yeah because after queen c7 it looked
like she never got back into the game
everything
went into your favor
i was really confused by knight b6 i had
no idea what the idea of it was
right yeah of course she has to find a
way to get the b pawn moving right yeah
if she doesn't do that there's no way to
open your position i think she missed
knight b5 here to be honest
like that looks like a very nice uh
inter mezzo
and right now author bishop d7 you had
uh knight xd6 was that your plan yeah i
was looking at it um i thought
um knight takes i mean bishop d7 knight
takes d6 she would play like
knight two
oh yeah yeah i was considering rook c8
and i was like if i take on c5 then she
takes on c5
and then queen takes rook c8
that's a that's a cheapo
yeah i was looking at this i thought she
would go for this
um but maybe
the rook first right knight takes c8
rook 68 and then just move the kingdom
in
is that enough
yeah i think so
i mean i was not expecting knight d7
though
like
i thought it was just really passive
yeah
it just felt like she played the kings
union and then she played it too safe
yeah or at least try to play it to save
which never works with the kings union
and uh yeah you went on to convert quite
uh smoothly after that congratulations
rochelle you're going into the last two
rounds and by the way did you have any
moments to uh check your friends game
jennifer's no i mean
like when i like browse other people's
games i feel like it doesn't really
register in my head i'm just like
walking around
um i like look at the position for like
a bit and then like i kind of just
forget about it
cool cool well still two rounds to go
still a big chance for you to
potentially get the title good luck
thank you for the games
rochelle uh it it's hard work for us
it's hard work for us to be commentators
we're gonna invite you to do our job for
us wonderful we want you
to tell us what you think of the game
between sophia and jennifer
which side you would prefer and why
okay then we're gonna go to sleep
go ahead give it your best shot the last
move was
these these were the last moves and you
tell us
if you think jennifer
is your choice
or if you think sophia
is positioned would be your choice
yes or so much pressure i know
and your clock is ticking
[Laughter]
okay i
i feel like i would prefer to be black
here um
like white's bishop is kind of
not in the game
like both bishops i guess
um like black's putting a decent amount
of pressure on e4 right black has more
time
i wait is what's the material is it even
even yeah yes
yeah i think i would prefer to be black
here
what would you guys prefer we're gonna
we we're gonna invite you to be a
commentator
in the very very near future thank you
and good luck in the championship rounds
coming up rounds eight and nine
wonderful by the way we have another
result i hope
andrew